i know you opened a restaurant that's
doing real well tell me about this
restaurant what's it called
the restaurant is called chicken and
beer man it's named after my third album
that went triple platinum humbly
speaking but to bring it from
an idea an inception of just an album
name and then make it into
a restaurant which is in the busiest
airport in the world
atlanta hartsfield jackson airport
concourse b is amazing so chicken and
beer do you like chicken
yeah who doesn't like chicken i love
chicken do you like beer
i love beer okay well there you have it
man you got to come to chicago
now uh well i had a restaurant for about
a year
just called the potato and all you could
get was a potato
that was it i'm not believing this right
now
trying to get in touch with my irish
heritage and it was just you could get a
potato and you couldn't get it different
ways it was just a baked potato that was
it
you know i don't i'm not offended
because a lot of people used to say that
i look like
mr potato head but because that's why i
got this afro
i really started getting away from that
but yes man i can respect the potato
and and uh all of its vitamins and
minerals
yeah well that restaurant folded very
quickly